ALEXANDRA PELOSI:
So, how did you
get into the Capitol?
JANUARY SIXER: (OVER PHONE)
I just walked right in.
PELOSI: January 6th
really activated you.
Yeah.
PELOSI:
What was it inside of you
that made you think,
"I'm gonna go
inside the Capitol"?
(COMMOTION)
PELOSI: I've been on the road
meeting some of the Jan Sixers
who were sent to jail
for what they did that day.
Did you go to the Capitol
to assassinate my mother?
No!
PELOSI:
You're rocking your MAGA tattoo
and your Trump socks.
There we go.
PELOSI: I can see you're taking
the sentencing very seriously.
You're the first January Sixer
to walk in
and take a felony charge.
It was a peaceful protest
that was hijacked.
PELOSI: Johnny, what if
you're wrong about everything?
I've been wrong before.
PELOSI: Do you feel like
you were a little brainwashed
by President Trump?
(PHONE BUZZES)
JANUARY SIXER 2:
I feel so remorseful
for what I did that day.
PELOSI: The left says
that you're domestic terrorists.
The right says
you're all just tourists.
But the United States government
thinks you're all
insurrectionists.